now then it's time of course for the
special distinction award mmm as an
artist reading one's reviews is a
dangerous game I mean art is subjective
so how could one opinion have more
import than another
does anyone need to be told what's good
or bad for example you're going to a
restaurant if you get lost you pull into
a gas station you ask for directions but
do you also ask the gas attendant what
he thinks of the chili actually I
usually do so maybe we we do need
critics no I'm sure we don't our percent
of the special distinction award is one
half of a rather infamous film
critiquing team I have seen his reviews
of all of my work and he's my favorite
half please welcome Roger Ebert
[Music]
thanks Kevin I'm my favorite half to
what I do bring regards from my other
half people at the airport always say
things to me like aren't you Siskel and
Ebert I know I should take off a few
pounds but Jean is in Chicago he is the
proud father of a three week old baby
boy and we're all very happy Uncle Roger
is happy the baby was born with two
thumbs such a heartwarming moment little
Jean leaning over the bassinet now baby
boy Cisco just as soon as you stop
sucking that thumb daddy's going to show
you how to make some real money with it
anyway Jean wishes he could be here and
I'm sure that he would agree with
everything I'm about to say for a change
I know he would because this is a film
that award is going to that we have
championed along with so many other
people that it was picked as the most
selected film on best ten lists last
year around the country by those hated
entities film critics the special
distinction award is given to a film
that doesn't fit within the eligibility
requirements of a spirit award the film
can be a documentary a short subject or
an animated subject and this year the
IFP West Board of Directors chose hoop
dreams
a documentary that moved audiences more
deeply than almost any mainstream movie
in recent memory an epic shot over a
span of five years and it's amazing to
me that when they started doing this
film they obviously had no idea how it
was going to turn out or what strange
twists of fate these two lies would take
this film tells the incredible true
story of two young men facing tremendous
obstacles in the pursuit of their dreams
what's most effective about this picture
is its emotional honesty it makes this
case very simply with no great fanfare
and you come away from it really knowing
and caring about characters that you see
all too rarely in American films
nonviolent inner-city African Americans
I believe for many American film goers
the inner city of America is a land more
unknown than the landscapes of Stargate
[Applause]
hoop dreams is a great film and a
shoo-in for an Oscar nomination so you
would think the documentary committees
failure to nominate hoop dreams or to
even look at more than 25 minutes of
Tara's Rygel's crumb is a scandal that
must not be repeated
let's take a look and see a little bit
of what the documentary committee
apparently was blind to the greatness of
hoop dreams
[Music]
it begins with the game with the basket
and the ball
it becomes a jury of heartbreak and hope
from city streets to the brink of faith
the amazing story of two boys
and two families struggling against the
odds
god bless she's always said to me
twosome Erica you can make something of
your life against the system you can
make their team when to make a dream
come true
all I ever dreamed about was playing in
[Music]
[Applause]
people ask me well I remember them if I
make it tell me if I don't
dreams an extraordinary true story
a unique motion picture experience
[Music]
and you see what a groundbreaker truly
was the first documentary made in the
shape of a commercial maybe it will win
a Clio award - I wish they had showing a
scene from the film I think it would
have been much more appropriate one
interesting footnote on Monday night
when the Academy Awards are being given
out William Gates who is one of the
subjects of hoop dreams is going to be
playing for his Marquette team against
Penn State in the NIT tournament at
Madison Square Garden
so that little kid that we first saw in
the 8th grade who said this basketball
is going to take me out of here and help
me amount to something has had his dream
come true the IFP West recognizes hoop
dreams is a great achievement and we're
happy to present the special distinction
award to its creators Steve James
Frederick Marx and Peter Gilbert
[Music]
[Applause]
well this is great this is my Oscar
thank you I have to quickly thank a
couple of people here one is car
tempered films in Gordon Quinn who gave
hoop dreams of filmmaking home in
Chicago we went in there with the
proposal absolutely no money and we
stayed there for eight years and they
kept us it was pretty amazing and I'd
also like to thank Katherine Allen at
Katy CA Public Television in Minneapolis
KT CA came through for us in really very
desperate times and their money that
they got us allowed us to continue
production and it's important to
remember that institutions like her
Templin and films like hoop dreams are
funded with PBS CPB NEA and other public
monies
please join in the fight to keep PBS in
the NEA alive and then there's some
other people here there's john schloss
who's out there who is our friend and
lawyer and probably lawyer for half of
the people here and i have to thank the
folks at fine line Liz man Sara Eden
Mary Ann Colton Nevins shallot Bryan
Caldwell for taking the Spill mountain
with great passion and dedication and
all the new fineliners Ruth Battalion
Mitch Goldman who are also here and then
I have to do a special thanks Tyra
Deutsch Minh who bravely took on - IRA -
who bravely took on a three hour long
documentary about inner-city families in
basketball IRA was always there for us
he always returned our phone calls and
he was a great friend all the way
through this and also to the gates and
AG's families I love him well Peter
thanked everybody so there's nobody left
for me to thank but that won't stop me
from talking I have a rimshot
okay but I'm fun at any rate it is
really important I think just to
underscore a couple things that Peter
said and and people that he thanked
because the truth of the matter is the
latest Tibetan monks that we have here
tonight are our own Tibetan monks and
that is the NEA and the CPB and the PBS
and these are our own governmental
institutions that help make this film
possible and if it weren't for those
governmental institutions we wouldn't be
able to get this film off the ground and
there would be wouldn't have been any
opportunity for fine line newline
anybody else to see this film down the
road and take it to the next level so
it's very very important again that we
all sort of recognize that you know if
we want to see
like coop dreams in the future it's
really important that we support these
institutions
[Music]
it's round two for newline thank you
seeing the demo tape tonight you know I
was the the trailer I'm thinking wow
this is really is a good film I'd like
to see this myself
and it just illustrates once again I
think some of the tremendous work that
fineline put into helping to get our
vision out to the broad American public
and they did such a tremendous job and
there's there's one thing that really
comes to mind in particular to me and
that is back in early November when the
film had been out about two or three
weeks and we had gotten this massive
wave of publicity we thought things
could not possibly be getting any better
than this and we thought we've got to
get this film out to hundreds of
theaters if possible because that's
always the conventional wisdom get it
out fast and hard and and people will go
see it well we were on the phone all the
time talking to IRA and Liz man and the
and the great folks at fine lines saying
please we're missing our opportunity and
there were all kinds of people who are
telling us if we don't act fast the
window will close and our chance will be
finished and Ira especially was a
tremendous voice of patience and courage
and saying no we've got to sit on it
we've gotta wait and if we're patient
the audience will get there and in fact
we kept it very small for a long period
of time last fall and when it came time
Christmas time and beyond and they
opened it wider and it's still playing
in theaters today and that's six months
later and that's all due to the great
wisdom and patience of IRA doorman and
Liz Mann and those folks I want to thank
them very much
lastly I just want to thank Susan Taylor
who is the love of my life and who's
here with me today and I always manage
never to thank her at events like this
and I want to tell her how much she
means to me her support is everything
thank you dear
[Applause]
well we made you sit through a
three-hour film so you have to sit
through three hours of thank you this is
my favorite award ceremony because this
is the first one I've been to we've been
to a lot this year this is the first one
where you get to go the honey wagon go
the bathroom I need a better writer I
just want to add my thanks to Peter and
Fred's
and also say that you know I I think
back to in the middle of shooting hoop
dreams when when things were really
going bad for the ag's and the gates
particularly the AG family when they
were on welfare and when Arthur's dad
was out of the house and and when Sheila
didn't have a job
and I mean everything was at rock-bottom
for them and I remember talking to
Sheila on the phone and she would say
that that she didn't she felt like when
this film was done that people would
hate them that people would look at
their lives and think that they're bad
people
and I used to tell her that you know
Sheila no that's not going to happen
that that people are going to you know
see this film and they're gonna look at
you and they're gonna think maybe for
the first time for a lot of people
they're going to understand what you go
through and what millions of inner-city
families go through in this country and
then at the New York Film Festival last
October when it when it opened we were
sitting up there in the balcony and at
Avery Fisher Hall and there were like
3,000 people there and I was sitting
next to Sheila for part of it and she
you know knocked me in the ribs and she
said you know look look at all those
people out there they're looking at our
story and they won't even get up and go
to the bathroom which I couldn't think
of a higher compliment for a film that
and by this honor that you give us today
you you honor them and your honor their
stories and your honor their
determination and their dreams hopefully
you know the rest of America and
particularly Congress can look at a film
like hoop dreams and look at what goes
on in the inner cities of America and do
something about it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you happy now now it's a real award show
they went off the wrong way I love that
ah oh we're still here right now we have
a moment in time when I need to
introduce the executive director and I
should tell you a little bit about it
she's a Harvard grad an actress a
journalist she hails from Arkansas which
of course coincidentally many years ago
President Clinton then governors signed
the first check to sponsor the IFP why
he was asked why his response was I just
love all those Russ Meyer movies have
you seen him that's just good writing
please welcome Don Hudson
[Applause]
[Music]
hi y'all I want to thank all of you who
gave your time not just to make this
event happen but to create a home for
independent filmmakers a place to meet
to talk and to learn how to scam free
processing from photo cam and deluxe -
David Burton Morris Victoria Wozniacki
Ana Thomas and Greg Nava who created the
IFP West Greg they were great
Greg and Ana rented out of their
bedrooms out of the bedroom for the
first two and a half years we are sorry
they had nothing better to do in their
bedroom but honor that we were their
fallback and to Jeanie Lucas who like a
true independent created a spirit Awards
with no budget and few resources thanks
yeah although we have more things here -
my dear friend Kathy main president of
Alpha cine he spent much of the last
five years as chair of the Spirit Awards
to the occasional delight of her
employers and I also want to thank our
longtime friends especially the Eastman
Kodak Company who has supported a spirit
awards from the very beginning all of
you here today who brought us here today
bought tables you are increasing the
opportunities for independent filmmakers
by contributing to IFP west thanks to
our incredible producer of today's event
Diana's on she's worked with many of you
she's great I know many of you who
worked with her so you don't need me to
tell you how fabulous she is along with
our production team Pam bachi Heidi
paevey stage manager Rick Bassman or
production crew over 100 volunteers and
I want to thank the IFP Wes staff for
your total commitment to the cause
[Applause]
special thanks to our leading sponsors
bill Schoonmaker
Martin Grossman Bakker and Franco bossy
CEO from swatch Bob Harvey of Panavision
Marion schwendemann and an OSHA Akkad
Entertainment Weekly
Kathleen door yes
Kathleen door and Jonathan searing of
Bravo and the independent film channel
I'll make that a very special thanks
once you hook up the independent film
channel in Santa Monica thanks also to
the 80 members of the press here today
who have increased the national audience
for independent films by having the
courage of their convictions that not
every great motion picture has to be
based on a Saturday Night Live skit
thank you for writing about these weird
obscure films we need your support and
of course thank you to our nominees all
the writers directors actors producers
cinematographers who make films not for
money or recognition or even a spirit
award just because they can't not make
them and now I want to introduce the
president of our of IFP West Barbara
Boyle
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm not gonna talk about rabbi Sol
of a chick today because you've heard
that story before
but I am gonna say one more thank you to
the very special dawn Hudson thank you
for this great party as Kodak wrote in
this wonderful ad that they took IFP is
dedicated to recognizing and inspiring
excellent in the field excellence in the
field of independent filmmaking
what is that field is it a fashion to be
independent now is it a trend I think
it's a movement a movement that is loud
and clear and powerful of you all and we
applaud you for this and you should
applaud yourself for this actually I
think what we've done is have a very
unique marriage and as many of you know
I have a very unique marriage I've been
married to the same man for 35 years but
the unique marriage that I'm talking
about today is the marriage between
Commerce and art something that has
eluded others in this town who also make
movies but it doesn't seem to elude us
we've made art that is pure art that is
unique art that is bold arc that is
individual and you know what we're
actually making money with that art and
that is another reason to applaud the
mighty Miramax the glorious Goldwyn the
outstanding October the very new New
Line fine line any line and all those
who have financed many of your films
here today so let's thank them and let's
be glad our films have returned money to
them
IFP has been and continues to be the
point of a triangle that's growing and
growing a movement that we feel as an
organization has been very important
first to service our members and we've
done that as many of you know with many
of our activities but even more
important to begin to be an influence in
the community last year this time we
talked about project involved 20 in the
inner-city young women between then when
we talked about it and now that we've
done it have made a film the next
Allison Anders the next Jodie Foster the
next we don't know but we dream and hope
because we made it happen for them the
second thing and big thing to announce
today is a capital fund for an
independent film center a center not a
metaphor a building where filmmakers can
show their films can meet each other
even more the resources of a library the
resources are individual talents it is
our dream and the third and last thing
that is very unique to this particular
year is again commerson art and I'm
going to talk for just a moment about
swatch interesting what they've done to
the face of watches but more interesting
because they're celebrating 100 years of
filmmaking with three independents our
very own Altman Kurosawa Amador beau in
their wonderful series and for that we
are all grateful and pleased
independence everywhere and to introduce
this unique and wonderful award that
swatch has empowered us to give to give
back to our community is does everyone
know who Sam Jackson is do I know do I
need to do an introduction the last time
I had the pleasure of introducing Samuel
Jackson I was so overtaken by how
good-looking he was in person that I
actually blushed but this time I read
his bio and the most interesting thing
because all of you know the
credits is he was actually expelled from
Morehouse College where he went to
school in 1969 what for the failure of
that college to have a Black Studies
group talk about independence talk about
spirit I applaud you all I thank you all
and I bring you Samuel Jackson to give
the swatch award
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon
how's everybody on behalf of the IFP
West I'm pleased to present the first
annual someone to watch a war a twenty
thousand dollar fellowship fully funded
by swatch Incorporated the idea is to
help a film artist who is exceptionally
talent talented but has not yet received
widespread recognition what's unique
about this award is that it provides the
recipient with a significant amount of
cash without dictating how it is to be
spent he or she can pay off credit cards
use the money as finishing funds or pay
the rent while writing the next script
in a word this award provides freedom
this year's recipient was chosen by a
five-person selection committee the
committee received 97 nominations from
around the country representing a new
generation of independent film artists
the man they selected is known as a
genius in the world of no budget
guerilla filmmaking his first
feature-length film is a dark disturbing
portrait of madness you want to point
your eyes anywhere except the screen but
you can't help with watch it's
definitely not multiplex material a film
company that shall remain nameless
offered him money to shoot a second
script on the condition that he tack on
a happy ending he refused and is now
struggling to raise the funds to make
the film on his own terms
we hope this award will make a
difference in his career just as we know
that he will make a difference in the
American cinema
I am honored to announce the winner of
the swatch someone to watch award and
the director of clean shaven lives
carry on
[Applause]
[Music]
god this is a shock of his actually
waiting in line to get the bathroom kind
of glad I got back here in time it's a
complete surprise to to the people
responsible thank you very much
gee I will be able to pay my rent maybe
I can get a ticket back to New York
thanks a lot I really appreciate it
means a lot to me thank you
[Applause]
remember when everyone dressed that way
at this award show what the hell
happened to us
our honorary co-chair person really
needs no introduction
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm Harvey Keitel again no oh boy
you know there's those of us who have
done this for a long time know that
there are really two reasons to come to
this great event
well actually three one is the weather's
always really nice and there's little
boats out there and you know that kind
of thing the other is that you get to
see a ton of people that you've worked
with a million times or a few times and
somehow never seem to connect with again
John Turturro for me gabriel byrne oh
boy the list goes on Harvey Keitel and
the other reason of course is to slag
unmercifully everyone anyone associated
with those nasty studios so since I
since I'll leave that to the rest of the
guests and I certainly done my share of
slagging I'll pass on to a great guy
somebody I know that you all know he's
done of those wonderful films that we
all loved and continued to love all of
the the some of the great films of Spike
Lee and also oh the Coen Brothers and
not to name a few and a few movies with
me as well some of them unnamed the last
the last film which I'm sure you've all
enjoyed him in was quiz show where he
played the the wonderful of Herbert
Stempel
I always hating introducing people's
credits because I don't know anyways
it's just it's too much too much memory
the the reason why I think we all speak
of him as the epitome of independence is
that he has this unerring and courageous
ability to play some unconscious thing
that we all know that we all can see in
ourselves and that sometimes we have a
real difficult inability to express in
my work I often talk about the different
choices that I've made as an actor as a
director as an actor I choose to play
characters that aren't me characters
that are people that I wished I was or
that I wonder about or that I say well
what if I had been born here would I be
more like that
an opportunity for me to kind of become
intimate and personal with a place that
I was never allowed to be and certainly
for for John Turturro when you look at
his roles that philosophy is kind of
operative just in the film that he did
with me where I went by my first
independent word here was five corners
and in that movie basically he he
carried me around for about 80% of the
film yes
deadweight I was he carried me around he
threw his mother out the window and he
smashed a penguin over the head with a
baseball bat oh yeah
that's pretty much the epitome of who
John isn't right what better way to
start talking about somebody but by all
the things he's not he's not kind of an
over weight now at all no he's he's
certainly not a you know a groveling
coward he is a great actor and loves and
is inspired by playing different sizes
personality shadow sides his personality
but I think the thing that is most
revealing about John and about his work
is the film that he directed Mac which
is one of my favorites when I know you
all agree and the most important part of
independent filmmakers is that they're
able to talk about their work have the
directorial process be about Who I am
what I think where I've lived who I've
loved and where I come from and in Mac
if you remember it's about a man who's
trying to build something trying to
build something desperately and giving
every ounce of himself his blood in his
history quality his family even giving
up his relationships in order to build
something that he feels is important
that somebody maybe will love and that
somebody will live in and that somebody
will appreciate and somewhere towards
the end of it what if nobody wants to
buy it and what if nobody wants to live
there does that mean it didn't happen
I don't think there is a better better
analogy
although that was quite facile but I
don't think there's a better analogy for
the independent spirit
in filmmaking than just that little idea
in that movie which is yeah it did
happen and it doesn't really matter
whether other people believed it to be
so and it doesn't matter whether it
touched people in the same way that it
did you the most important thing is that
you've reached out and I can't think of
anybody who has reached out as much and
as well as John Tudor
[Applause]
[Music]
no thank you
I didn't know there was going to be this
many speakers before I delivered this
keynote address so bear with me and well
I'm flattered that I was asked though I
must admit that I had a little
trepidation about giving a speech to
this large audience my choice my
personal choice would have been
Christopher Walken
hi I'm Chris Walken I I had a speech in
my head I have a head wound I had a
speech
the writer me wrote the speech I've been
carrying around for two years up my ass
I love I love Chris so I do have a
speech and don't worry it's been in my
pocket so and I'm gonna make it no why
am I gonna make it well because I didn't
get nominated this year for an Academy
Award and I want to make a speech a long
speech I heard that Francis Ford Coppola
spoke here for two hours I don't intend
to go that long they wanted a really
long speech they would have asked Martin
Landau now let's let's talk about why
wasn't nominated all right
because if Miramax had distributed quiz
shop the poster that everyone hated the
back of ray Fiennes head Harvey and Bob
would have been sure to pan down his
back and show that he had no pants on in
the isolation books independent film so
many images flash across my mind when I
think of independent film I think
independent film I think independent
film scale
scale +10
no heat dressing room walls that you can
look over one shot we got to do it in
one one shot I line arguments is it left
to right or is it right to left to watch
Dennis Hopper as a director in an
independent film they deal with this
problem was the ultimate he would say
man is it left to right man all right -
laughs fuck it man now we gotta do it
both ways man - fuck it man that's true
that's a true story
independent film independent foe
hysterical a DS hey come on we gotta
move how many setups 43 before lunch
come on we losing the Sun it's not even
up yet I'm myself if that's a very
interesting experience as an independent
film I did this one film where I had
just killed someone and the scene was
set in the bathroom it was a terrible
film anyway so I got prepared for the
scene I run up and down the stairs I
stick my finger down my throat I take my
private moment I rushed into the scene
and I have gloves on covered with blood
and somehow the blood has dripped from
the gloves onto my hand and I don't know
if that happened with OJ but it happened
with me so I throw the gloves off and to
the sink and I try to wash the blood off
my hands and being fiction of course it
doesn't come off and I turned to my wife
in the scene it's all in one shot of
course and I say look III can't get it
off my hands and she says so what I got
it on me - I should dye my hair with it
anyway we shoot the guy says cut great
out-of-focus we do it again so I put on
the the gloves now the gloves are wet
right because they I threw them in a
sink and I noticed that they were wet
and I asked the ad do we have another
pair of gloves
he asked the costumer the costumer looks
at the producer who's sitting there with
a girlfriend half his age
the answer is no not so I say do we have
a hairdryer no not enough electricity
all right so they shake the gloves out
they blow on them I do my preparation I
think about how much I want to kill
these people i rushing through the scene
I can't get the gloves off I'm yanking
them I'm biting with my hands I'm
thinking about how are we gonna cut this
scene it's one shot it's gonna be five
minutes long right
finally I get them off I turn to my wife
in the scene and I say and I say the
scene look I can't get it off my hands I
look down and to die from the gloves are
all over my hands I have black hands so
she says I should dye my hair with it
I'm saying yeah sure cut so anyway tell
the 80s I come over here come over here
I said I take out about $80 I hadn't
cash it took it out of my pockets I say
here go run get another pair of gloves
right away another small film I did
which hasn't been released yet I had to
perform a complicated disco dance while
I delivered a long speech I was costume
in a typical form-fitting tight disco
outfit and I had to be miked under the
costume now usually they have elastic
belts with the pouch in it when you put
your battery into and there's a Velcro
closure to hold it in place well the
sound man didn't have one of those he
just has an ace bandage which he wraps
around my thigh and my waist and he
takes the safety pin and he puts it
right under my buttocks to fasten it
so I said to the guy you know you know I
have to dance right III I have to do
half splits right don't worry don't
worry don't worry I say you have no tape
no all right okay all right sure
actually I do the dance I do the half
split the pin goes right in my ass I do
my best
Martha Graham contraction like this cut
I call the sound man over I say you come
over here I pull my pants down the pin
is in my ass I said here's $20
go buy some paper clip some velcro and
some alcohol to clean my ass I take the
pin out I give it to him low-budget
always carry cash
[Applause]
a lot of cash it's hard to make a good
film and it's even harder when you have
no money yet as we see this year and
throughout history it's been done from
when Renoir to Rossellini who spawned
the neo-realist Visconti De Sica rosy
and of course Fellini to Wells to
Bergman to Truffaut - Cassavetes to
Peckinpah to Scorsese - the filmmakers
gathered here today it's been done one
of the first independent films I
remember seeing was John Cassavetes
husbands it was on television one late
Saturday night and I sat there watching
it with my younger brother Nicolas who
see it today and I remember us dying
laughing at these three men in the film
and not really having any idea that what
we were laughing at all I know and all I
knew that it had something to do with me
the characters were unpredictable
idiotic and confused by love it was like
watching my own family
I remember thinking someone knows thank
God we're not alone when people talk
about films today the first thing that
pops out is did it make money how much
did it gross you rarely hear what did
you think did it affect you did it leave
you with anything what they're talking
about is money not film now there's
nothing wrong with monetary success but
when gross alone is equated with success
when it becomes the sole criterion it
degrades some of our greatest artists
Jean Renoir's rules of the game was a
commercial failure when it came out as
was Citizen Kane sweet smell of success
and Raging Bull among others I've met
people of this business who talked about
Raging Bull on masterpiece my favorite
film I watch it every week yet they
never produce it they never even think
to try to produce it but they love it
it's like loving your wife but never
sleeping with her we live in a time in
which we found the lowest common
denominator money this room is filled
with young independent filmmakers who
have made their first or second film
each of which is stamped with their
personal imprint
as they continue to develop an outlook
as they struggle to open a window on
some unknown landscape they will be
asked they will be tempted now that
you've done your personal thing now that
you've gotten that out of your way what
do you really want to do don't you want
to make the films I want you to make
don't you want more people to see your
films yeah but see what that's the
question we all have to ask ourselves to
look to be able to see the artist has to
be aware of the world he or she is
living in roberto rossellini once said
if the artist can't in some sense act as
a guide to point the way if he is unable
to take his bearings and say today at
this point in time these our these are
our horizons then the function of the
artist disappears his function is to
clarify things
I personally believe when artists give
of themselves they bring their knowledge
to life and make it comprehensible to
everyone it's what's known as
civilization despite what Newt Gingrich
might say we live in a crazy world we're
bombarded by images invaded by
information what do they tell us
mostly they fill us with anxiety there
was an incident last year in New York a
man by the name of Colin Ferguson got on
the Long Island Rail Road a train that
my family and I have written our whole
lives he stood on the train with an
automatic weapon loaded with ammunition
killing six people and wounding 19
others a year later in court he refused
to use a lawyer choosing instead to
defend himself acting the part of a
lawyer as he watched other actors do on
television interrogating witnesses who
he had shot and maimed asking them so
after the accused shot you you closed
your eyes did you not and the witnesses
replied yeah yeah yeah after you shot me
I closed my eyes so you wouldn't shoot
me again uh-huh
so you pretended you were dead yeah yeah
yeah right so you wouldn't shoot me
again your
may I see the weapon no mr. Ferguson no
you may not
huh I'd like to see it I'd like to see
it no this is one of the problems mr.
Ferguson
when a defendant represents himself
after watching this farce with my mouth
open I thought this is beyond theater of
the absurd this is beyond anything I've
ever seen this is the world we live in
how does one even attempt to reflect on
such a thing most people run away they
stay off the trains for a while they
stop watching the news they move as far
away as they can possibly go escape
escape is the goal the question becomes
do you disassociate yourself from
humanity most commercial films of
today's support this this is what we see
a refusal to look at the world an
escape-and-evasion is basically
decadence we go to the cinema and we see
the same story over and over again aimed
at 10 year olds well I'm a person too I
want to be aimed at too we see the same
false solutions
Fellini said when you show a true
problem and then resolve it the
spectator is beguiled into feeling that
the problems in his own life too will
solve themselves and he can stop working
on them for himself by giving happy
endings to films you go Geordi Anton to
going on living in a trite bland manner
because they are now sure that sometime
somewhere something happy is going to
happen to them to and without their
having to do anything about it
conversely by not serving them their
happy ending on a platter you can make
them think you can remove some of that
smug security then they'll have to find
their own answers to have faith to
express what you know and have the
courage to persist in the face of
rejection to trust your instincts and
have the will to follow them leads to
discovery that comes from freedom not
formula that's how originality is born
I've met people in this business who say
to me I'm gonna make a lot of money and
then I'm gonna do what I want later on
the truth is of course they never do
without realizing it their ideals their
thoughts their love becomes less and
less a part of them and once you lose
all those things you don't have anything
I'd like to conclude with a story that
was told me a story Roberto Rossellini
used to tell it was part of a sermon
delivered by Saint Bernardino of Siena
it's short one day a peasant had gone to
work in the fields and had brought along
his son and a dog he had left the child
under a tree and the dog to watch over
him and had set off to work upon his
return he had found his son with his
throat cut open the child had the mark
of two teeth on his neck the dog stood
by the tree shaking all over in a fit of
rage the peasant killed him but after he
had killed it he noticed that on the
child's body there was a large snake
which had obviously killed the child
while the dog had tried to defend him
the peasant feeling sorry for the
innocent dog whose name was Benigno
buried it under the tree and wrote an
epitaph on its grave that said he lies
Benigno unjustly killed by the rage of
man as time went by the people who
passed by the grave would stop and not
knowing that Benigno was a dog prey on
his grave
and so veneno started making miracles
indeed so many that one day the people
of the area decided to build a church in
which they meant to bury the bones of
this Benigno as they were transferring
the bones of the presumed Saint they
realized it was a dog Saint Bernardino
used to conclude a sermon by saying that
what mattered most was what was in the
soul of the people who went to the saint
in faith and not the fact that the saint
was a dog thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Harvey Keitel very serious Roger
Ebert guys who won the thing for hoop
dreams Samuel Jackson pretty much reads
John Turturro articulate hysterical and
stifle engaging big glass never ever do
award show with John to true then now
it's time of course for the Fendi
friends of independence award here to
present is a man who produced and
co-wrote eat drink man and woman react
yes you're allowed to plug that film if
you'd like the we have some of the cast
and crew here from that film but a
Taiwanese delegate where are they ah
[Applause]
whoa Henchy Juan's ovooed anger I just
told them that turnaround is a good
thing Joel Silver is a soft-spoken man
and lady will meet Mike Ovitz he's the
caterer now then defendi acknowledges
individuals and organizations who have
shown themselves to be preeminent in the
support of their independent filmmaking
community here now is that man and where
the hell is his name is he ready yes
good Jon Seamus please welcome John
Shamus
[Music]
it's a pleasure to be invited back to
the spirit Awards I called them the
Supreme Soviet of self-congratulation
ceremonies and I'm here to be handing
out the vaguely though inexplicably
obscene sounding Fendi award I told my
mother I was giving San with findi this
afternoon she said be safe Sam Goldwyn
jr. that's his last name
more than implies is Hollywood royalty
born with the golden rolodex but Sam
chose not so much to abdicate his throne
as to find his own unique path toward
independence and integrity and self
congratulation um he and his eponymous
outfit have been with the independent
movement from the beginning think of
stranger than paradise and on too wild
at heart go fish last year's big loser
the Independent Spirit Awards the
wedding banquet and Henry part 5 King
George the 3rd Henry the fifth you get a
sense of a career that hit maximum speed
at the start gate and isn't showing any
signs of slowing down now Sam was a
gentleman whose pride extends over the
remarkable group of people he has
gathered at his company and to adore him
and sure his films get nominated for
lots of Academy Awards like every
independent film seems to be getting in
these days but Sam also produced the
Academy Awards when that sideshow used
to have some real class just like the
stars of my other favorite Goldwyn
production American Gladiators yes it's
a it pays the ran come on you know Sam
knows how to dodge those slings and
arrows and wiffle balls of independent
life he is the American Gladiator of
independent film ladies and gentlemen
please welcome a guy who still calls
movies pictures the Silver Fox of
Independence Sam Goldwyn
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Jim not John I'm very
flattered to accept this award on behalf
of not only myself but of the Samuel
Goldwyn company because we're a team I
think you all know how much we care
about independent pictures and in line
with that I'm pleased to announce as you
know these tables are ten thousand
dollars apiece and all of the I've been
informed by the Independent Spirit
people that all of the money collected
today will go for the startup and
completion of independent pictures isn't
that wonderful I can't think of any
other organization that would do that
with such a good spirit and they're
gonna kill me for saying this seriously
though much has been said about
independent pictures today some rather
lengthy some rather short they're going
to continue there will always be
independent pictures but kid yourself
not this current boom that the studios
are showing in behalf of independent
pictures will be short-lived if those
pictures are not successful because kid
yourself not the studios are not
independent filmmakers they are large
corporations multinational only
interested in the bottom line you are
the spirit of that future that will keep
pictures alive you are the writers
directors producers and actors and that
is a very sacred trust because the
studios when this independent boom is
over and it will be over will start be
looking very shortly at interactive
because Hollywood unfortunately only
copies and when three guys can raise
over a billion dollars in about six days
that's where the future is going to be
for the studios so you have a flame and
to keep that flame alive lies on your
necks
and while people will tell you don't
make films that are going to be
successful because that's part of the
so-called spirit make films that will be
successful because your pictures can
entertain can entertain people look at
pictures like for weddings in a funeral
an independent picture look at the films
like pulp fiction and independent film
and there's a lot of them out there that
are being made by bright imaginative
young writers directors and producers so
guys go at it spend that money from the
independent film spirit well and go at
it thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
the principal has left the building
this close to wearing that tie here's
the thing I'm slamming everybody baby at
this point many of you are wondering hey
where the hell is buck Henry that's
Pollock putts blows for you we have this
buck Henry fix roll it now please and
here it is the Independent Spirit Award
itself the Independent Spirit Award
statue designed by Carol boss'll 'men
symbolizes the independence spirit this
bronze sculpture and I'm quoting now
features an abstract bird symbolizing
the independent filmmaker taking flight
from atop a classical column
representing the classical Hollywood
studio system clutched in the talons of
the bird of independence are entwined
shoestrings in the shape of pieces of
film an allegory yes analogous about the
budgets within which independent
filmmakers must work or you might think
of it as representing one of the escaped
Disney studio experimental cost-cutting
message service homing Falcons flying
backwards for secrecy and carrying the
latest microfilm leveraged buyout offer
from a Japanese media consortium to the
cleverly disguised false greco-roman
maildrop
outside of the CIA garage
and now I had the pleasure introducing
an actor that I along with gaben Bern
worked on with in this film the usual
suspects
he's pretty inspiring to work with it's
one of those earned while you learn
deals and it was a pleasure to work with
him and know him please welcome Kevin
Spacey
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much Kevin is is right we
work together in the usual suspects and
we had a marvelous time on this film but
as you've seen Kevin is something of an
impressionist I did not know that John
was but we used to drive Gabriel Byrne
nuts all through the shooting because
Kevin does a great Johnny Carson
impression and and I've done one myself
and so every day all through shooting we
just sort of stand around and we do
Johnny and nobody cared as they don't
hear but we used to drive Gabriel nuts
and Gabriel wanted to learn how to do
Carson so every night Gabriel go home
and he'd work on this he'd stand in
front of the mirror going oh yes that's
funny funny stuff he never got it right
I feel sorry for you Gabriel but keep
working on it this year you know we've
talked about how great the year has been
for independent film but they've
actually given me the numbers to to
prove it there were a hundred and twenty
submissions this year the Independent
Spirit Awards 29 of which were nominated
it is the most in the 10 year history of
the Independent Spirit Awards and also
what was very encouraging was there was
such new talent on display there were so
many rookies who stepped up to bat and
really hit one out of the park that the
IFP felt the need to recognize that so
this year for the first time there are
two new categories the best debut
performance and Best first screenplay so
congratulations to those of you who have
started a new trend this year
and the the range of work this year it
really really spanned the globe it was
rather amazing it took us from the main
streets of the Bronx through suburbia in
rural Maine all the way as far as Taiwan
and Red China Latin America Spain and
and the subject matters that these films
dealt with were difficult and
challenging ranging from child abuse
schizophrenia incest and those were just
the comedies and that old standby murder
and as usual the IFF staff has assembled
highlights from this year's nominated
film so it's my pleasure to introduce to
you a little taste of this year's best
we've got back baby in the faces beat
down but you missing something I'm gonna
enjoy my I don't get happy and be quick
about it okay now I'm gonna show you how
to walk
[Music]
the beautiful and irrepressible Dorothy
Parker everyone wanted to know what was
on mrs. Parker's mind but no one ever
guessed what was in her heart I fall in
love with married men but I do it on
purpose I I drink too much and that's
because I'm thirsty
mrs. Parker suppose a bit more of it
does it take and I write to Dad's
because it's a doodad kind of town you
can get by it's a fancy car
is that warrants mine how coming in
American Warren says it's the best car
for on you but I'm sure he must know
Hauser Lane she's okay should be nicer
to her
I don't remember asking your opinion
you're gonna die young dear boy
yeah well it's got to be better when
you're dead right there always felt that
I could make up for something I did
isn't my fault Tommy left
you chased him away
[Music]
you wanted to be a farmer but you chased
him away right you told me you wanted to
see me look maybe we should do this some
other time I know you got a lot of balls
sending somebody to my father's house my
father is a sick man
you know something Ralphie by the way
you're acting here looks to me like the
Acorn doesn't fall too far from the tree
and you're the one with the big balls
and maybe a little bad attitude to go
with it my bad fucking attitude is my
business I saw my fucking balls and I
don't really can't feel like either one
how do you like that
[Music]
erna is starving she almaty watts
he specialized in this management
[Music]
so what do you kids been up to today
well we killed two cops on the way over
here and we got married and we saw
ourselves on TV for the first time Wow
looks like the only thing you do how bad
is your marriage it's not what you think
I can explain it was Wayne I had nothing
to do with it one day he comes home and
says pack your bags the next thing I
know I'm on the FBI's most wanted list
what am I supposed to do Michael he's my
husband I was in love with him there's
supposed to be a half million dollars in
that safe
he must have moved it we can find it
Michael we can be together we can go to
Mexico Mexico leave here early I guess I
hope you like seafood
just a word seafood I think gives me the
creeps
by the very high tolerance to pain cool
you know that I was attracted to you
because I thought you were a writer yeah
don't remind me
that things I've done like what's the
coffee
but is the only thing that I believe if
something is fun their kids are not
gonna stop
something makes them do it everybody
knows it's wrong they do it anyway can I
get you a cup of tea
[Music]
this because I enjoyed it doesn't mean I
didn't know it was wrong
just watching the world pass you by I
think as long as you ain't drowning
everything's all right New York City
five million dollars I'll give me a
Porsche and a boy who's about to learn
that survival means saying nothing
that's like playing each piece like
losing it hurts you want my king you've
got to come get my king all these other
pieces are just a means to do ready for
the real thing
ready to come get it you ready to be the
king what is everyone talking about I
don't understand I don't know what it
means I don't know what it means to be
here you tell me I'm intelligent listen
to easy do you know what you work for
power what have I done to you
[Music]
go Nicole
who are you
[Music]
I'm your father you remember me
but if you
your grandmother Gladys is my mother
[Music]
you always play by yourself
lady
maybe we could play together so you left
the children alone in the room you
locked the door and then you gave the
key to Sara who lives in the house no no
I did not give the key to say that I
gave the key to Jill Jill with the Jay
not Sara Jill doesn't recall I knew
Yolanda we're now gonna do anything
stupid are we don't you hear them
nobody's gonna hurt anybody
we're all gonna be like three little
finds he's here and what's Fonzie like
come on what the mundo and that's what
we're gonna be we're gonna be cool how
is it that we know who we are
we might wake up in the night
disoriented the wonder where we are
we may think perhaps that we have lived
through what we just dreamed or we may
wonder if we are now still dreaming but
we never wonder who am i because our
knowledge of who we are is the richest
most stable and most complex memory
structure we have they are the
structures which connect us to our pasts
and allow us to imagine our futures to
lose those connections would be a sign
of pathology pathology called amnesia
but it makes no sense to begin the story
here without its history it's past so
let me take you back to a time before
identity has been confused
[Music]
what happens when the story dies the
evil is set free
now that the films have ended the genies
out of the bottle
that's what the nightmares are telling
me and that's what I'm writing this is
still a script we're talking about right
once you've decided crossover out of
films into our reality Danny what is
stopping us to make another movie please
proceed with your statement I don't know
you haven't ever seen you before but I
don't know what it does you think I've
done obviously she's insane she's not
responsible of what she does but you're
a lawyer if you don't stop this right
now you're an accomplice you mean we're
gonna have to pay the price you
threatening I'm not yes you were let me
make this clear the time for people like
you making threats is over huh out there
maybe you bastards are still running
things behind the scenes but in here and
here I'm in charge
look she just got out of the hospital
who's gonna take care of her oh there's
gotta be somebody's not the end of the
world taking good care of your mother
Raymond your clerk paid to do a job you
can't just do anything you want while
you're working
what kind of convenience store do you
run here job would be great if it wasn't
for the customers I don't bother them
and they don't bother me I could do
without the people in the video store
just that one was that guy who was in
that movie that was out last year you
should hear the barrage of stupid
questions I guess what do you mean
there's the license you mean I got a
drink this won't be hot you feel a hell
of a lot better if you just rip into the
occasional customer great people been
loved gatherings isn't it ironic since
he was a child
the me
bird in his head was perfect so he spent
his life trying to let others hear it as
he did
you
Said's all clapping before nice
important is young junior white red a
[Applause]
beautiful woman enters the world of a
stranger a man whose secret will lead
her into a mystery and whose past is
inexplicably linked to her destiny
whatever happened inside the walls of
this orphanage is to stay inside the
walls of this orphanage that is a sacred
rule a rule more sacred than any rule
you will the story of three sisters
looking for a recipe for romance and
their father one of the world's great
chefs trying to understand the
ingredients in this family
if you can't cope you can always cook
three women with a taste for life and
dad just tried to stay on the menu
laughter one part passion with a dash of
intrigue and adventure mixed in I just
want to find a girlfriend and have them
no catches no glitches no booby trap
the girl you're gonna meet doesn't look
like anyone you know and when you meet
her your toes might tingle or you might
suppress a yawn if you want some tea or
something how long do you think it'll be
before they consummate it's gonna be at
least two or three more days two or
three more dates what is this a lesbian
Gandhi I just hope this isn't gonna be
one of those unrequited love stories
[Music]
Linda Fiorentino is Bridget and Bridget
is bad bad to the bone in your own place
yes I know it's clean Kevin door
plumbing you need three million bucks
and all I have to do is kill someone
when you go apartment honey
maybe it's my point small-town morals
but I don't do murder yeah well you
would if you loved me
murder is commitment when I've done it
in you haven't it why do you act in an
ordinary way all right
you drink you gamble do I please stop
you said that we work not to create but
to destroy gifts that are given from
above so why do you do it you don't have
to do it
please don't drink please I won't drink
you won't drink anymore no give me your
word of honor I give it thank you by
saying I'm an artist and I won't change
a word of my play to pander to some
commercial Broadway audience now let me
tell you something kid that's the real
world out there and it's a lot rougher
place than you think
you gotta do what you gotta do we can do
the play a single going for the whole
show the firm is it Nick it's a boom
stick your nose in other people's
business and I won't get broken
[Music]
Sabrina lectures here's the wiggle at
this joint home bunk you know think of
quarters of the things with her
I have a confession to make
no don't speak don't speak don't speak
silence be or not to be that's where it
goes monkey glands are working I think
maybe I'll go and check into a
sanitarium and get the help that I need
and we'll talk later because it's been
good yeah her spinal cord touches her
brain it's an assignment that will
require a lot of diplomacy intact
really surprised it gave to you you can
see Americans are not more violent than
other people no all those people killed
in shootings in America oh shootings yes
but that doesn't mean Americans are more
violent than other people
where's better shots I think it's true
that the height of the sexual revolution
is over I don't go to bed with just
anyone anymore I have to be attracted to
them sexually but I was thought that
women had to have some kind of profound
emotional bond with a man before they
became interested in a relation of that
kind don't think any Americanism is
really all that significant a phenomenon
that's really nothing is a person but
you seem very intelligent for America
well I'm not time of the afternoon has
come for some cappuccino I don't know
about you to present cinematography to
major participants in the independent
film world as of late although we
discovered him as la Bamba
and she's still homina homina homina
Rosanna Arquette and Lou Diamond
Phillips
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for Best Cinematography are
Greg gardener for his striking black and
white treatment of suture Alexander
grusinsky who caught the syncopated life
of the Bronx in I like it like that
Steven larner who captured stark beauty
in the beans of Egypt main zhang lin who
photographed telling detail in each
drink man woman and john thomas whose
elegant compositions grace barcelona and
the spirit award goes to there it is
I thought it folded John Thomas
[Applause]
the winners all the way in the back set
to walk up front it's crazy
[Applause]
I'd like to thank some of the people
contributed the look of this film Chris
tell us in the editor edy giguère
wardrobe designer Chema betina's
production designer also photo film and
service vision of Barcelona Eastman
Kodak and Technicolor in New York I'd
like to think I thank our terrific
Spanish crew for their hard work and
kind hospitality I'd like to thank whit
stillman for his unique vision and his
loyalty my wife Betsy and her boys Jack
and will for their patience and
understanding and finally I'd like to
thank the IFP and all of you who support
independent film thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
all righty
aah Oh Oh bitch is gonna make it good
airplane overhead
Stephen Dorff will next be seen in
Halcyon by the way I love your golf
videos I like that one
and he's presenting the first screenplay
and with him to present this of course
is the number one answer to the question
who's your favorite Judd Ashley Judd and
Stephen Dorff
[Applause]
[Music]
and who's your favorite basketball team
not UCLA the Kentucky Wildcats that
ominous for Best first screenplay are
paul zehrer for the gothic drama
blessing Kevin Smith for clerks a
hilarious no budget look no budget look
at New Jersey slacker life James Bosley
for fun a searing portrait of right and
wrong David O'Russell for spanking the
monkey a 90 suburban answer to life
without mother or like with mother I
never saw that I'm too young and Tom
Noonan for what happened was the story
of incest and cannibalism on a first
date and the Spirit Award for Best first
screenplay goes to you think that like
he and I together we'd be cool but but
we're both really nervous David Russell
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much there's a lot of
well-written independent films this year
so I feel honored and I'd like to thank
Janet and Dean and Jeremy Alberta and
Karla for their great performances and
everybody who made this real cheap movie
thank you very much that was first
screenplay now we have of course a
Spirit Award for screenplay the two
presenters Amanda Plummer and Tim Roth
of course did some amazing work in Pulp
Fiction without question Pulp Fiction
the wonderful film of course that brings
a huge box-office star like Bruce Willis
to the brink of anal sex and then as
Christopher Walken explained the rectum
has a wonderful hiding place but here
first is now Amanda Plummer and Tim Roth
[Applause]
[Music]
hello right-oh nominees for the best
screenplay are Woody Allen and Doug
McGrath for bullets over Broadway
queenly wine James Sheamus and only for
eat drink man woman Alan Rudolph and
Randi sue Coburn for mrs. Parker in a
vicious circle Quentin Tarantino for
Pulp Fiction John Doe and Richter offer
read request and the Spirit Award goes
to Quentin Tarantino for Pulp Fiction
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not sure Avery it wasn't on the
thing
sorry Rocha you want me a job
ah hi everybody I don't know if I'm
gonna win anything else so I'm gonna say
everything I was gonna say here and if I
win something else I'm not gonna say
anything except thank you so if I win
it's a real quick night alright on
everything else the one thing I just
wanted to say with all this talk about
studio non studio independent studio
money no money box office no box office
Bulova all that stuff is it was very
interesting I had a very kind of an
interesting experience just as we were
in beginning pre-production on pulp
fiction and that was the fact that true
romance was coming out all right and I
had said that I would like you know go
through the whole press junket and
everything and do the press for it
whatever and and like they had been
having all these market research
screenings for true romance which was
done by a big studio is done by Warner
Brothers alright and I think was yeah
okay was Warner Brothers and like the
audience's were flipping out and
everyone was talking about how good the
movie was and and this and that in the
other and I'm like thinking wow this is
great you know and then I saw the movie
and I liked it like a well this is a
real audience picture you know you show
this to an audience they're gonna like
enjoy it then true romance opens and
like doesn't do very well alright
there's like you know drastically less
like and then they thought in their
opening week all right and then it goes
down the next week all right you know
and then like I think ended up topping
out making 12 million dollars and it
costs I don't know 12 and a half million
dollars I don't know what a yeah but the
thing is it just didn't do well alright
after all this publicity and everything
and I remember thinking to myself well
shit
I guess I just don't make audience
pictures I guess I I guess my audience
is very small and that's just the fact
of life that's just that you know I'll
never hit with a big audience and right
at the same time Jane Campion was
kicking fucking ass all right with the
piano all right I was doing well harvey
keitel means as much as jack nicholson
overseas because of the piano okay and
then I remember talking to Harvey
Weinstein and thinking to myself
basically well if Jane Campion can do
what Jane Campion does and find a big
audience well I guess the thing is to
just keep on doing what I do and either
it will or it won't but that's not to be
decided and pulp fiction found that
audience and I guess the number one
thing I just want to say is don't change
it for anything else other than just do
what you want to do and either it'll
find an audience or it won't that won't
be your fault that's not your fucking
problem all right the problem that has
nothing to do with you the thing is do
what you do and I guess that's what I
got to say thank you very much
I really have nothing nearly as profound
to say other than this probably would
not fit up my butt as well as an Oscar
would but this is means just as much to
me so thank you very much
[Applause]
I'll be selling this later
I'm sure there's got to be some other
rectal references coming at you tonight
it's going to happen deal with it
embrace it before it kills you
but now teacher to supporting male which
we all love
he of course acting directing a great
deal of work in the last few years in
fact a new film coming out that he
directed from his father's screenplay
about the Black Panthers this of course
entitled Panthers and she is pretty much
stealing hearts with before sunrise in
killing Zoe Julie Delpy and Mario Van
Peebles
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so the nominees for Best Supporting
male are Giancarlo Esposito as Esteban
the chilling drug dealer in fresh chat
spamming Terriers teach-in bullets over
Broadway larry pine for his performance
his dr. Ostroff the haunted physician in
Bonnie on 42nd Street Eric Stoltz as
Lance the lay back drug dealer and pulp
fiction
and Nicholas Turturro as Ralph the kinky
housebreaker in Federal Hill and the
Spirit Award goes to chess commentary
[Applause]
[Music]
well first I'd like to thank the
Independent Spirit Awards for the
community for giving me this award I'd
like to thank excuse me the cast and
crew of bullets over Broadway
the mayor max Brothers for doing such a
great job distributing it Harvey and Bob
who are not only movie studio heads
their movie their lovers their film
lovers and I really want to applaud them
for the way they handle movies well I
think we should give them a round of
applause I'd like to thank woody and
Doug McGrath for writing such a great
script for woody for his brilliant
directing for letting me and everyone
else in the cast be free to try things
and to do different things for Colin
DePalma for his great center photography
which I really thought got overlooked
them I just want to say a special thanks
to Kahlo for the cast Dianne Wiest and
jennifer Tilly and John Cusack who I had
so much fun with him such a terrific
actor Jack warden Jim Broadbent Tracey
Ullman it was like going to a Broadway
play every day and it was such a
wonderful time appearing with these
people to my lovely wife Gianna and to
my baby that's coming soon and to my mom
and dad and especially to my dad who
said the saddest thing in life is wasted
talent so I'm glad I made good thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
chaz also in the usual suspects god
bless him way to go chats Best
Supporting female will be presented to
you by two of the stars of a well she's
a star of little woman of course one of
the stars there are so many fabulous
actresses in that movie and he has two
films coming out that's it copycat and
how to make an American quilt here are
Samantha Mathis and Dermot Mulroney
[Applause]
[Music]
vs Brody as Eli the commitment-phobic
lesbian in Go Fish
Carla Gallo is Tony Peck the analysis
crazy girlfriend and spanking the monkey
also Kelly Lynch as Roberta the sultry
object of desire in beam to reach a moon
Brooke Smith for her portrayal of the
lovesick Sonya and Bonnie on 42nd Street
and Dianne Wiest for her performance as
the outrageous grande um and the Spirit
Award goes to
don't speak
Dyan Ruiz
[Applause]
[Music]
oh gosh well this is just amazing
oh I can't say what I've written because
it just doesn't seem to apply thank you
first of all the Independent Spirit
Awards for giving me this I just stand
up here in many many many people's debt
and I guess I just have to name them so
first of all to my loyal friend Woody
Allen who just gave me a gift with this
role he just handed me a gift and - Doug
McGrath is such a wonderful writer -
Chaz and Jennifer - Dear John Cusack and
all the casts and all the crew the magic
of carload of commas lighting Chaz I
think I'm giving your speech again and
to be in Jeffrey curling's costumes it's
also a great comfort to be represented
and taken care of by a mother tiger
called Tracey Jacobs and a pussycat
called Sam Cohn and I think Barb and Bob
and Harvey Weinstein's very very much
and Miramax and Bobby Greenhut and Jean
de Manian my mom my dad I wish they
could be here my brothers Greg and Don
my extended family and my two daughters
Emily and Lily thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
without sounding a bit didactic at that
bang was extremely talented in the
speech yes one importantly I forgot to
tell you that Dermot maroney's ban
sweet'n low Orchestra will be performing
at the fabulous party that's happening
afterwards at thank you at the Barker
hangar Santa Monica Airport so don't
miss that please the next category
foreign film this is pretty cool because
uh growing up I thought that's what
independent films were but it turns out
they have their own category at the
independent film awards she Mimi Rogers
you can see in bulletproof hearts and
reflections on a crime and he of course
is soon to be seen in the Cure please
welcome the extremely gifted Mimi Rogers
and Bruce Davison
[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started I just want to
take a moment to remember a great
independent filmmaker from Canada that
we lost this year much too soon
Phillip Borsos won an Academy Award
nomination for his documentary nails he
went on to make the gray fox the mean
season Beth Yoon and Mimi and I had a
chance to get to know him and love him
and work with him this year he will be
missed
anyway the nominees for the best foreign
film are blue kite tins Wang's Wang's
compelling look at China's Cultural
Revolution through the eyes of a
working-class family
Chen's Wang's Wang producer the boys of
st. Vincent John in Smith's epic
examination of sexual abuse in a church
run orphanage Claudio Luca and Sam
Khurana producers ladybird ladybird Ken
Loach's heartbreaking study of a misfit
single mother Sally heav'n producer read
the final film increased off Kozlowski's
acclaim three colors trilogy focuses on
the chance encounters that connect our
lives Marin car mats and Jurado a
producers 32 short films about Glen
Gould Francois Gerard's kaleidoscopic
biography of one of the greatest
musicians of the 20th century NIV
Fishman producer and the Spirit Award
goes to red Marin Carmen says you're
either way
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo
I will speak little in English I don't
apologize for my English which is not
very good so in the name of Chris of
just love ski and our partners and k2
production my gametes and dolphin kissed
of the new sea we are very very happy
and honored to receive this award red is
the last installment of this
extraordinary adventure that was a
production of the trilogy three colors
blue white and red this European
co-production was truly exemplary at all
level it gave to each of the partners in
spirit of our cultural differences so
possibility of offering is competence
and its commitment to one of the
greatest director of the last 20 years
Christophe gesture of scheme and I will
thank you all of you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like I would betraying my comedic
brethren if I didn't somehow make this
voice now my son Phillip goes into the
water
to avoid the Blowfish Best Debut
performance something we'd all like to
win is the next category to present this
Louis I love these people because both
names you really need help pronouncing
and that's such a part of show business
now my name's been misspelled on posters
and trailers the lawsuits about Laura
San Jacomo is by the way how you say it
Giacomo relax
Joo como she'll be seen and Nina takes a
lover or has been seen yeah and James
look grow we should get that guy back up
it to say these names perhaps in
floundering here they are to present
best debut performance please welcome
them now
[Applause]
[Music]
hi the nominees for Best Debut
performance are Jeff Anderson for his
portrayal as Randall and clerks Jeremy
Davies as ray in spanking the monkey
Shawn Nelson for his performance as
fresh in fresh alicia witt as bonnie in
fun and renee zellweger
as star lean in love and a 45 and the
Spirit Award goes to Shawn Nelson
[Applause]
[Music]
mm-hmm well I'd like to thank God my
mother and father my family and I'd also
like to thank Boaz yakin Doug Abel
Lawrence Brenda
Randy Ostrow Giancarlo Esposito Sam
Jackson the Boucher right Joanne Fraggle
Eddie Jensen and the entire cast and
crew afresh I'd like to thank Miramax
Lola Louise Donna Dickman and Susan
Novak I'd like to thank John Shea and
Copeland Karen David and everyone at
frontier booking and whoever else helped
me get this war
[Applause]
[Music]
I just love that it took a brother to
get up there to thank God that was the
first time I love that congratulations
the kids marvelous in the film I don't
know how many of you have seen it it's
pretty amazing
pretty damn amazing director that's who
we're honoring now oh that's the sound
of sphincter-tightening yes slipped it
in and now here to present the Spirit
Award for director she diane ladd just
besides being a previous Spirit Award
recipient has completed her directorial
debut with mrs. monk hope that's the
correct information and he a good friend
of mine soon to be seen in Nadia the
Christ Sheikh he's the father of Bridget
mr. independent fucking film himself
Peter Fonda and Diane Ladd
[Applause]
[Music]
the free or die that's right I do go for
it it says almost does it me Jamie yeah
Eddie well the nominees for Best
Director are Jon Dahl who juggled an
array of twists reversals and double
crosses in Red Rock West's on Lee who
dramatized the timeless clash between
tradition and individuality and eat
drink man woman Roman Polanski whose
mastery of suspense created chilling
intensity in death and the maiden Alan
Rudolph who blended wit and pathos in
his portrait of a bygone era mrs. Parker
and the vicious circle
and power jacket of the day Award winner
Quentin Tarantino who with his gallery
of articulate gangsters created a brand
new kind of film hero in Pulp Fiction
and the Spirit Award goes to Quentin
Tarantino
[Music]
whoa getting this from the wild angels
is like too cool I gotta tell you it's
always think oh my god this is a reunion
of the wild angels oh my Jesus Christ
other than thinking Bob and Harvey
Weinstein and Richard glass scene I'm
gonna keep true to what I said I'm just
gonna say thank you and everything else
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
nice try hazel you left me a bunch here
best male lead the moment you've been
waiting for a few of you to present best
male lead of course is one of the stars
of a new film called The Cure Anna Benna
Annabella she ora
another one of them great names and
Brendan Fraser will also be seen in
professional man and the passion of
darkly noon here are Annabella and
Brendan
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon
well the nominees for best male lead are
samuel l.jackson first performance as
Jules Winnfield the hit man who
dispenses fire brimstone and hot lead in
Pulp Fiction
young lung as mr. Chu the Taiwanese chef
who confronts the erosion of traditional
values in eat drink man woman William H
Macy is John the professor engaged in a
high-stakes verbal tug-of-war in Oh
Leona Campbell Scott for his portrayal
of Robert Benchley the humorist with a
serious responsibility to his best
friend and mrs. Parker and the vicious
circle and John Cena first performance
as Chino monado's the young father whose
act of petty larceny sparks the
life-altering chain of events and I like
it like that samuel l.jackson
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you first of all I need to thank
the IFP for giving me this war and next
I have to thank people in order I have
to thank my wife for telling me at one
point during my acting career that I was
a bloodless actor and I needed to get in
touch with my emotion so I could
communicate to people and hopefully I've
done that next I'd like to thank Quentin
for writing this role with me in mind
and having that meal that told me he was
gonna do that and sending me the script
next I need to thank my managers Julie
Silverman Eli Selden and my agent called
hacking for calling the Weinstein
brothers Harvey and Bob and the other
producer Danny DeVito and Stacy Cher and
Michael Schaumburg when Lawrence and
Quentin thought they might not want to
use me in this role and telling them
that they had to let me audition for
this role on an equal basis thank them
for that
and I'd also like to thank that
wonderful cast that was in fo fiction
that created the world that all of you
fell in love with and made possible and
especially like to thank John Travolta
for his friendship
and his sharing and mr. harvey keitel
for being such a wonderful wolf when he
showed up to hang out with us and I'd
especially like to thank Tim and Amanda
for making that diner seen everything
that it could possibly be and sharing
that space with me and becoming a truly
ensemble thanks so very much
[Applause]
[Music]
we've come to the point where we're
going to present one of these fine fine
trophies to the best female lead and to
do so two presenters he actually hosted
this event and also helped to certainly
publicize what it takes to get a film
from notion to screen he being Robert
Townsend he helped to put a lot of us I
think on the map and she will soon be
seen in Don Juan DeMarco more
importantly I was mesmerised blown away
and frightened by her performance in the
movie Network where she had this
exaggerated over-the-top insane Network
executive it wasn't until I actually
moved to Hollywood took a few meetings
and I saw the subtleties of her
performance Faye Dunaway and Robert
Townsend
[Applause]
[Music]
you were the first one to do it on
credit cards so the nominees for best
female lead are Linda Fiorentino for her
performance as Bridget Gregory the
coolest femme fatale since Diana
Christensen in the last seduction
Jennifer Jason Leigh as Dorothy Parker a
writer whose wit masked the brittle soul
in mrs. Parker and the vicious circle
Karen sillas as Jackie the brilliant
Arthur trapped in the body of a lonely
secretary and what happened was Lauren
Velez as Lisette Linares a young mom who
faces questions of family fidelity and
career in I like it like that
and whoo Chen Yin for her performance as
judge in the rebellious airline
executive in eat drink man woman and the
Spirit Award goes to
[Applause]
give me a break
Linda Fiorentina for the last seduction
[Applause]
[Music]
huh let's see I've won a few Critics
Awards I'm in a couple of magazines this
month I have a job I have a lot of job
offers and I haven't been laid in three
months
so I was wondering if you don't mind me
trading this in for a date with Gabriel
burn
[Applause]
um let's see I'd like to thank Steve
buran sick for writing an incredible
role for a female he's a very nice man
but I do not want to meet his mother
I'd like to thank Peter Berg for
allowing me to emasculate him each and
every day on the set somehow he managed
to maintain his dignity teri dres back
for dressing me so well on a shoestring
budget Jeff joy the cinematographer for
making me look human on my 18th hour of
work my sisters Terry and Rose who hate
flying but they came here to be with me
this week because I really missed them
my partners in media crime
Nancy Ryder and Julie Jaeger and last
but not least Jon Dahl a great filmmaker
a great friend a great man he had more
confidence in me than I'll ever have in
myself thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell he's just sitting there
fart
what's the matter with you now the
chrissake did you not hear what she said
[Laughter]
my God in heaven above already mm-hmm
are you happy I invited you now to
present the spirit award for first
feature she not nominated today but is
nominated on Monday for her performance
in Little Women and he has an absolute
gift and a face you immediately love
when you see it on screen here's Winona
Ryder and Lukas Haas but both be seen
soon and boys by the way
[Applause]
nominees for best first picture are
clean-shaven directed by Lodge Kerrigan
clerks kevin smith director i like it
like that
directed by Darnell Martin spanking the
monkey David O'Russell director and
suture directed by Scott McGee and David
Segal Spirit Award goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I did not expect to be up here again
a lot of good films this year thank you
very very much I can go on a little bit
more at length and I can thank the
wonderful actors Jeremy Davies and
Alberta Watson and Carla Gallo who
brought a very difficult story to life
and it was a real balancing act for them
you know the story could have become
maudlin it could have become gratuitous
at any turn and then they worked real
hard to save it from that and thank you
for honoring such a difficult and odd
film I really appreciate it and hope it
will inspire me to make more difficult
than odd films thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so he won Best first screenplay and
first feature that's awfully hate him to
present best feature we have two very
distinguished and inspiring spirited
actors or is Mary McDonald soon to be
seen in Joshua Tree and Laurence
Fishburne can be seen in Just Cause and
higher learning Mary and Lawrence
[Applause]
[Music]
hello the nominees for best feature our
bullets over Broadway the hilarious
demonstration the true artists come in
all disguises Robert Greene hunt
producer eat drink man woman a comic
look at food fatherhood and family ties
Ted Hope Lee Kong shoe and James Sheamus
producers mrs. Parker and the vicious
circle a sober look at New York's
drunken wits Robert Altman producer pulp
fiction a rock and roll portrait of the
underworlds working stiffs Lawrence
bender producer and Wes Craven's new
nightmare
the king of Horrors unleashing of freddy
on the real world Mariana
Madalena producer and the Spirit Award
goes to pulp fiction Lawrence bender
producer
[Applause]
[Music]
I get to keep this first I want to say
I'm so thrilled for Sean back there
and Sam's agents didn't have to call
everybody we were just trying to make it
hard on the guy you know we want to get
him ready for that role I want to say
first of all it's really a thrill to be
standing up here in front of mr. Harvey
Keitel to be on the same podium that he
was on it was only about four years ago
that I got this message on my machine
from Harvey and saying that he wanted to
speak to me about this movie Reservoir
Dogs and it's it's only four years later
and I'm standing up here in front of you
guys and it's thanks Harvey's been a
constant source of inspiration to
Quentin and myself and he's like a older
brother as we were coming in here a lot
of people are asking you know the
question you know independent versus
major and so you know and what's the
difference and not to belabor a point
that everyone's belabored but I do feel
that it's important just to remember
that it's a it's you know you could have
an independent movie in a major you
could have a movie made by committee and
a formula financed by your uncle it's
not what matters it's it's it's to have
the courage of your own convictions to
have the the just have the integrity of
your own creative beliefs not to
second-guess and I think we're in such a
great time right now in American cinema
and I'm really proud to be a part of it
these last few years have just I think
shown a lot of great new talented
directors and I'm thrilled to be a part
of it and as I'm saying this I'm
thinking Pulp Fiction is like the studio
of independent films at 8 million
dollars you know in Hollywood cents is
nothing but you know compared to Robert
Rodriguez
it's like 1,200 times his budget or
something
so god bless Robert I want to thank
Quentin Tarantino who I am very thankful
and lucky to be his friend and partner I
would love to thank all the actors
including Sam just for their amazing
performances and of course I want to
thank the amazing crew the one thing
about making independent films is the
crews not only have to be technically
great not only have to be creatively you
know there but their heart and soul has
to be really in this movie you know we
use mostly everybody from Reservoir Dogs
on pulp fiction I don't think we can
make a movie without these guys and I
just want to thank Sally McKee our
editor David wass core production
designer Betsey Hyman our costume
designer Andre our our cinematographer
Paul Holloman my line producer and my
post supervisor Heidi I want to thank
show well for being with me throughout
this process which wasn't easy and I
want to thank mr. Richard Gladstein over
there who won when Reservoir Dogs was
when we were doing Reservoir Dogs
you know Quinn and I were just another
couple of filmmakers and you know
Richard and Rana had the power of the
pen there and every single thing from
the makeup person all the ways to
whatever and these guys support us all
the ways through and so thanks so much
because he didn't have to give it to us
then and lastly I want to thank the
kings of rock and roll the kings of
cinema Harvey and Bob Weinstein for
their amazing support now and forever
thank you
[Music]
well it has been fun
indeed and I want to remind you to come
and have fun with us I've been told here
two bands pool tables that's always an
incentive as you rush to the doors I
want to thank you very much for having
me you enjoyed anything I've said my
agent is here George Freeman if you
didn't don't tell anyone